the late show with stephen colbert is
taking a big big step into a
post-pandemic world
cbs's late night talk show is welcoming
back a full
and the most important part fully
vaccinated studio audience starting
three weeks from today
now this is the first network late night
show to make that move
meg oliver's outside the ed sullivan
theater that's home of the late show meg
this is a really big deal very exciting
i'm happy for the colbert fans
and for the colbert team this is good
gail this is so exciting on june 14th
these doors will open and welcome some
400 audience members
something that hasn't happened since
march of last year
[Music]
this is the stephen colbert we remember
from before the pandemic
a host who loved getting up close and
personal with his studio audience
even once graciously accepting an
emerald ring
it's not quite it's emerald courts
but when the pandemic forced broadway
and much of new york to go dark in march
of 2020
the late show's ed sullivan theater did
as well
as you may have noticed none of you are
here right now only people in the
audience right now give me a shot of
this
only people in the audience right now
are some members of my staff hi
guys the broadcast felt so different
colbert and his staff changed the name
from the late joe to
a late show hey everybody after a brief
hiatus colbert was the first late-night
host to return to the airwaves
welcome to my bathroom broadcasting from
his bathtub
you're watching a very special social
distancing edition of the late show or
as i now call it the lather show with
scrub and colbert
soon he and the other late night host
did what we all did this past year
talked with people via zoom and they
managed to keep the laughter alive
without the energy provided by a live
audience
thank you so much for having me so good
to be here congratulations on the blog
this is as much this as much as anyone
is ever with anyone anymore
but now colbert has a chance to provide
much more than laughs
in welcoming back his audience he's
bringing back a sense of normalcy and
healing
like his predecessor david letterman did
just days
after 9 11. it's very simple there is
only one requirement for any of us
and that is to be courageous come june
14th
colbert's audience members will have to
show proof of vaccination
and face masks will be optional and then
after
437 days and 205
a late show will once again be called
the late show
thanks to this familiar sound
[Applause]
[Music]
no one knows what colbert will say
tonight about his audience's imminent
return but gail we understand you'll
have a chance to ask him as a guest
tomorrow
in a statement colbert would only say
he's looking forward to doing shows
again for an audience he can smell
and touch i know i think they're very
excited over there
and good you know listen they had to
fill out a huge questionnaire answer all
sorts of questions meet all sorts of
requirements right
but can you imagine how they pulled this
off you guys for the past four hundred
and thirty five
years we went through it so we actually
did our show in that studio
yeah and it'll be nice to have an
audience back because an audience gives
you
energy yeah and he's right when you can
smell it when you can taste it when you
can feel it you know it that well it's
tough
it's tough being a comedian when they're
proud to laugh at your jokes and
musicians
artists comedians they they also have a
responsibility in moving things forward
right
new normalcy whatever it's going to look
like i can't wait for oh i asked i'm
curious about
who is the first guest going to be june
14th that's a very good question well
we'll have john batiste here later in
the week maybe he can help us
and i'll bet they won't tell us we'll
see yeah no i bet that one either meg we
thank you again